先生 すみません この偈は仏法の実践方法を簡単に説いているものだという話だったんですけども
四行目のシーラーと映しているとかですね
真理にかなった生活するというのはよくわかるんですけども
智慧があるっていうのは結果ですよね
智慧が出てくるというのは結果ですよね
それを実践するのは難しくて
これはやっぱり何か原因がないと智慧は出てこないわけで
サティを実践することで
そういうことから智慧が出てくるということになるわけですよね
いえ この偈だけ実践しても完成します
仏道は  その智慧の実践というのは？智慧の実践というのはどういうふうに理解したらいいのでしょうか
だから何一つも罪を犯さないんだと
何やっても罪を犯さないでやるぞと思ったら
それがサティですよ 気づきがなくできるわけないでしょうに
商売のために相談して喋ってるでしょ
儲かりたくて とにかく契約書書きたくて
あれこれと喋るともう罪を犯ってますからね
だから喋ってる間 ずっと罪にならないような
嘘にならないように喋らなくちゃというサティがじりじりと働いているはずなんです
やっぱり根底にはサティがないとダメということですね
だから完成した道だから
お釈迦様一言葉で説いたっても
すべて完成している 八正道は全部入るんです
四念処の実践も全部この偈の中に入るんです
そこはブッダのすごいところなんです
それで 私たち個人で実践しようと思えば
自分に分かりやすくて納得いくセクションだけ選べばいいんです
例えば この偈ぴったしうまく納得いったって気持ちだったら
それは自分の教えなんですね
自分に悟りを目指す もうポイントはそこだ
この偈になるんです それで
だからたくさん教えています
人にぴったし合う教えがどこかにあるんです
ないはずはないんです
だから私たちは教える立場だから
もう何でもそういう風に
ものすごく完璧に完璧であることを示しながら語るんであって
見事にうまく ああ これは私にも見事にうまくはめましたという人は
それで悟りに達しますよ
もうサティを実践しなくちゃというふうに引っかかっている人にとっては
これはちょっともう まあそんなこと言ったっても
これはそんな大した教えじゃないと思ったりする可能性もあります
それは個人の差なんですね
お釈迦様 あんまりそこまで気にしないんですよ
例えば 十の説明でね 十はいくつあるのかと
いくつでもいいんじゃないかと
百八でも説明しますけど
六でも説明しますけど
十八でも 一つでも十は一つやとも言うし
どうでもいいんじゃないかと
お釈迦様はそういう立場なんです
そういうことで 八正道といえば八ですからね
これはもう七つでいかがでしょうかということ
難しいんですよ 八正道の項目出しちゃうとどうしても八になっちゃうんです
しかし 八正道を全部まとめてこういうふうに言うこともできます
例えば この行四行聞いた人がお釈迦様は気に入りました
私はもうこれを実践したいんだと
違法的な罪を全く犯さないで生活するっていう仏道を実践したいんですから
もうちょっと具体的にやり方を教えてくださいと言ったら
その人に合わせて ではあなたは五戒守ってくださいとかね
生命に対して慈しみを実践しなさいとかね
もう朝晩はこういうことをやって
その具体的なことを言う可能性あります
何も聞かないで実践しようとする人は
八正道を自分で発見するんです
問題ないんです だから問題は簡単に言うんだけど
実践しようとすると二十四時間気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
子供笑ってよく笑ってくれるんだからと言って
何とかありともしない
いろんなものをやっぱりこれは嘘だからやめなくちゃとかね
ということになったりする
子供はもう一緒に散歩をすると
人の家の果物の木が道路に出ていて
これ手を取って何か取ったりすると
まあ一応子供のことだから
じゃあ無視しようとかね
人にバレない まああんまり人も本人も気にしないだろうとかね
自分が罪を犯しちゃったんですね
子供を愛するために 気をつけろ
その瞬間の時でも これダメやと
人のものやと あんた取ったらあかんこと取っちゃったでしょうと
言って 一緒にその家の人を呼んで
申し訳ないんで うちの子はこれを取りましたから
どうぞもうということで返してあげなくちゃいけないし
だからかなり厳しいんですよ
やってみると しかし 二
三週間でもよるかぐらいには足しますよ
例えば奥さんの機嫌取るで
あなたは世界一美しい美人だよと
言うと奥さんがすごく舞い上がりますけど
それは言わないんです
仏教の人は だから そうではなくて
まああんたのことはね
もう小さい時からもうね
知っていたんだから 一緒に遊んだんだからね
遊んでいて それで一緒になりましたと
他の人のことは知りませんよ
私はと あんたのこと以外はと
それは事実であって お前世界一美人だから結婚したんだよって
それインチキでごまかすというのは
まあ違ったね 後ではうまくいかないんですよ
それで あんたは私のこと好きでって
あんた何言うの？小さい時からあんたのことしか知らないでしょうにと
好きでも嫌いとも関係ないでしょうと
他の女知らないんだから
私はと 結婚するってあんたと結婚するしかないでしょうにと
これから死ぬまであんたと一緒にいるしかない
好きでも嫌いでも関係ないんだよと
ただそれで事実でしょうし
死ぬまで一緒にいるんで
その場合は 奥さんもやっぱりこの人には私しかないし
私にもこの男しかないんだよと
そこで愛着なくお互いに頼りあった頼りある生活成り立つのですよ
だから罪がなく それで夫婦関係成り立ってるんです
だからそういう風に実際やってみると
かなり智慧がないと 私はそれを具体的に言う場合は
皆さんも気づくと思いますよ
やってないんだからね
こんなちっちゃい単純なことで
そんな尊いサティに達するわけないんだと言ったら達しますよ
やろうと思った瞬間からもうガクンと思考が変わらなくちゃいけないんです
それでサティが働くし
もうものすごく智慧が現れます
だから智慧がある人は道徳を守るし
道徳を守るためには智慧が必要ですよ
だから一緒なんですね
そこも 智慧がないんだから
心汚れてるんだから 道徳破ったりするでしょうに
道徳破ること自体が罪を犯すことでしょうに
ということで すべて一つのセットで
だからこれやって それからこれやって
それからこれやって それからこれやっていうふうにはなりません
はい おかし質問がございますか？はい
一を見ても二を見ても三を見ても
絡めて絡めてというか
一体として観察するとしますと
我々の世間の基本にあるね
不正でない正しい方法
罪のない方法で自分のため
他人のため 子供を作ったり
財産を作ったり 権力を持ったりすることはいいというふうに考えてしまうのですが
正しい方法であれば 子供を作っても財産を得ようと努力しても得ても権力を得てもいいということ
になりますよ うん  2年ほど前に同じダンマパーラでご講演いただいたゲノ62というのがありましてですね
それにはこのまま死なず子供がいる私には財産があると思うなよと言っているのですが
このゲの最初の二行はゲノ62の一行目を見ていたと思うので
このゲノ64の第一の二行は同じだと読むことは別の文として読み直して考える考える考えるとかがそのカーストと仏教的な論理では
だからどちらでも真理でしょう
あった日あったのになって自分に自分さえもないんだよというところは
自分の肉体も法則によって動くのであって
私は若くいたいと思ったって若くいられませんし
もうもうしわがいややと言ったってしわが出るし
髪の毛も落ちて欲しくないと思ったって剥げるし
どうにもならんでしょうに
だから自分には自分さえもないんだ
だってこのアホが子供がいるんだと思うなよと
という話なんですよ だから別に問題ないと思いますけど
単純に法則によって変化しているんであって
だから生まれてきた人が子孫
財産 権力を得たい 得たい
成功したいと思うのは単純な法則であって
それで自分になるわけじゃないんですよ
家族がいたっても自分の家族になるわけじゃないんです
財産があったっても 全くの他人のもの
他人というか 他のものであって
外のものであり 自分の希望通りにはならないしね
権力あったっても見事でしょう
権力者の働きぶりを見ると
自分では何もできないことになっちゃうんです
面白いでしょう 例えば日本の一番権力
すべて憲法も何でも管理しているのは総理大臣一人になってますけど
その人に限って何にもできないんです
だから権力を握ったって
あんた何を権力を握ったんでしょうか
ただ 我々よりも自由がなくなっただけでしょうと
うかつに喋れないわ 喋ったことはものすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないし
もうちょっとでも誰か大臣がね
女は子供も機械やと もう普通のじじい言ったならば何のこともないでしょうに
普通のじじいが言ったら子供それ喜んじゃうんでしょ
女の女たちは 女はじいさん何言ってるのかというと
お前ら子供も機械ではないかとなんと言ったって全然気にもしない
それは女性差別心も何もないんです
かえって男よりは頑張りなさい
しっかりしなさいよ 大変でしょうという意味でも取れるんですよ
普通のおじいさんが言ったならば
その場合はもう私たちと違いますよという意味でしょうし
これが大臣に言うとどうなるのかと
大変ですよ だから権力を握ったということは
何も権力なくなったということみたいなもんなんですね
だからまあ 62で言っていることも
84で言っていることも
もう全部真理はそのままなんです
子供はいるのはいいんだけど
それ自分の子供になりませんよ
仕事をする上で お金が貯まったかもしれません
自分のものではなりませんね
体さえも自分のものになってないんだからということになります
ありがとうございます
うーん どうします？まだ質問があれば
はい  この子供 財産を権力を望まないっていうことと
不正な罪を犯さない 犯してまで自分の繁栄を望まないってことが 2つの項目だとすると
私は 1つの項目と言ってるでしょうに
ただ 真理を具現化するためには
やはりじゃあ子供とか財産とか権力を望まない方が早く
望まない方じゃなくて
不正に望まない方がなんだよね
財産なく生きていられますかね
だから財産というのは厳密に定義すると呼吸することでも外からいただくものでしょうに
酸素なく生きていられますかね
だから人はきれいな空気が必要でしょうに
それは昔は無料ですけど
今は無料じゃないでしょうに
それも 水がなければ生きていられますかね
だからきれいな水があることも財産なんですよ
それは昔は無料でしたけど
今はお金かかるし だからこの肉体の維持管理にはやっぱり物質ですから
他の物質は必要なんです
それは財産ということになるんです
あの定義をしっかりするっていうことも必要なんですね
ただ 世間の定義には則んじゃなくて
仏教はどんな言葉にもまず定義していくんですね
財産といえば物質です
その物質は肉体という物質を維持管理するために必要な補うもので
これなきには誰も生きていられません
で 期待する期待しないという話にならん
そんなのは期待 例えば美味しいものは期待しようがなかろうが食わなくちゃいけないっていうことなんだ
事実は それを不正で罪を買ってやるなよと
そういうわけで 財産を得ることは人生の目的じゃないんです
子孫を作ることは人生の目的じゃないんです
権力は人生の目的じゃないんです
それは目的じゃない そんなのは呼吸するために生きているんだとか
それは目的 何言ってるんですかね
生きてるんだから呼吸してるんであって
それはもう不可分でどうしようもないことだけなんです
だから不可分だから罪を犯してでも得るのは正しいっていうところで
もう一つの大事な法則を破っているんです
物質は関係ない 心ですからね
生命っていうのは  たまたま肉体がついてるだけで精神的な流れにいろんな肉体がつくだけのことであって
そこはもうではなくて
やっぱり罪を犯してでも肉体を維持する一時的な肉体でしょうに
そういうことで罪を犯すなかれと
それで心の法則は破ってはならない
法則破るとひどい目に遭いますからね
物質の法則でも破ったらやられますからね
もうどうにもならない
例えば家を建てると それは物質法則で建築技術は成り立つので
自動的に地震で壊れてほしくないと思うならば
3階の建物であるならば
柱にどれぐらい強くなければいけないかとかね
土台はどれぐらい厚く硬く作らなくちゃいけないかということはね
これは研究してもしなくても
自動的に答えができてしまうはずなんです
あの建築士はもう何か設計したら金がかかりすぎやとかね
この人はもう 5,000万のもの一千万で設計してくれたと
3階建物は作ったら倒れますからね
だからその例えば柱のね
鉄 鉄あるいは何て言いますかね
鉄骨を減らすとかね 鉄筋減らすとか
土台をもう 20 センチ薄くするとかね
いいんですよ いたっても一年もたないんですけどね
建物 それでひどい目に遭いますから
だってお金かかったでしょうに
建物潰れたら作った人もひどい目に遭うし
もうお金がないんだから
それで建築士はどうなるんですかね
会社倒産しなくちゃいけないし
その上もう裁判にかけられるし
冗談じゃないんですよ
ちょっとでも法則破ると物質法則破ったって
もうすぐ目の前で結果が見え見え
心の法則破ると もう直したらとんでもないことなんです
そういうことだから 子供を望むなかれとかね
そういう弱よ的な邪道的な思考じゃないんです
財産を望むなかれとかね
望むなかれって そこまで言葉はおかしいんですよ
望むか望まないか これはもう我々の管轄外なんです
ご飯を望むなかれと 何言ってるんですかね
管轄外なんです 栄養は取らなくちゃいけないことになっているんです
だから法則っていうのはそういうわけなんです
だからお釈迦様は望むなかれとは言ってないんですよ
執着するなかれとは言ってます
初めから自分のものではないんだから
初めから自分というものさえも成り立たないんだから
そういうことで あの もう切って理解しないでください
全然納得してないんだからね
どうしても切って理解してやろうと思ってるんです
でもつなげて 4行も一緒にしてください
切ると自分が困るんです
なんか矛盾にぶつかっちゃって
質問です よろしいですか？あの
自分の仕事は特殊なんですけども
あの 自分がその仏説として正しいと思っているものが
それはそうじゃないんだというのを完全に論破できないっていう状況において
嘘をつかなくて仲良くやっていくっていうのは
黙っとくのが一番じゃないかと自分は考えているのですけども
どういう  それは能力のない弱い人の思い泣き声以外何ともないでしょう
自分が頭悪いのは誰のせいだと思ってるんですかね
でも学者にこう例えば何て言うか
それはその違うとかって言われたら
自分がデータを全部集めてこないとダメだから
結構っていう感じになってしまうんですけど
データ集めなきゃわからないというならば
わかってないでしょ 初めから本人が
データもなしにどうやって違うと思うんですかね
例えば仏教は全く知らない人に偉そうに仏教を言うと
それっていうのは失礼もいいところでしょう
それはもう宗教を強引に押しつけることになるでしょうね
ただ自然に生きることは仏教なんです
自然にうまく問題なく仲良く生きると
この人の性格はすごいよと相手が感動するんであって
お釈迦様一人の仏教徒になりなさいと言わないで
ここまで仏教を世間に広げたんだから
一人の出家しなさいと言ってないでしょうに
どれぐらい出家がいるのかと
二人も一人にも強引に行ってないんです
一人にさ でも 私は違う人間だとか
仏教やってるんだからとか
それ時点で仏教じゃないんです
普通に世の中で普通に生きていて罪を犯さないという
具体的には サドゥパウパッサカラナという
その偈を言ったところで
それはお釈迦様が言ったんじゃないでしょうとかって言われてしまったら
どういうふうに答えたらいいかっていうのが
あんたすごいんですね
昔からあんた知ってるんでしょうかと
お釈迦様が誰が言ったんでしょうかと
それだけでしょうに  日本語で
それしかないです  あんたすごい天才やと
もう過去現在未来全部わかって驚いちゃったと
それだと私はさんざんこれはどうですか
あれは？とむちゃくちゃ聞くんです
だからそこは醜っていうことがね
知恵なんですよ 人間がもうただ感情で嫌で
俺が嫌いだからっていうところの理屈を持ってくるんだからね
俺が嫌いであろうか 好きであろうが関係ないっていうところはなんですよ
中身は それ以上だと厳しすぎだからね
それはそうじゃなくて
すぐ褒め称えてあげて
だったらこれも教えてくれと
サドゥパウパッサカラナはブッダに教えられたものじゃなかった
では私もブッダ何を教えた？もう調べているんですけど
本当に何を教えたんでしょうか
教えてくださいと あんたそこまで知ってるんだからね
サドゥパウパッサカラナブッダの教えじゃないと知ってるんだから
あんたブッダの教えを知った上で比較して言ってるんではないかと
だから ABCD がブッダの教えであって
これ E だ F だからブッダの教えではないんだということだから
アイデアを聞けばよかったのに
どうもありがとうございます
例えばこの偈はお釈迦様に教えたのは私に聞いたと知ったものじゃないでしょうに
理性ってそういうこと
これもダンマパダにあるんであって
本を読んだらブッダに説かれたとあるんであって
それで他の世の中の文献ではこういうことはないことも確かでしょうし
調べなくたっても ウィットゲンシュタインはこんなこと言ってるわけじゃないでしょうに
だからまあ 記録はブッダに説かれてあるんだから
いえ 違います よく言えるもんですよ
それが  比丘が説いたかブッダが説いたかっていうところ
ん？ 比丘が説いたかブッダが説いたかっていうところ
比丘が説いたと その比丘がブッダが説いたと言っているならばどうします？ そうなんですよ
自分にはもうそれで納得済みなんでいいんですけど
納得って言ったって もう私たちにとってはどうしようもないということなんですよ
だから私は内容に入るんですよ
中身見ろよと それにはかなりの智慧が必要なんです
だから中身を見るということは結構厳しい作業で
だから私は中身で見て判断するんです
別に注釈書であるんだからブッダに説かれたということを私もあんまり
ああ そうでしょうかということで反対はしません
言ってるんだからっていうぐらいに終わるんですよ
しかし 中身分析すると
この完全に語るということは人類にできないと私は知っています
神にしか言えない 神だから言ったんではないか
聖書の連中が コーランの連中が威張ってますけど
二行目もう矛盾なんです
一行目は一応設定だから矛盾だと言えます
二行目になってくると矛盾なんです
完全に語れませんよ だからもう完全に語るとすぐ結果が出ると
その結果は幸福の結果であると
実践してみれば これだったらすごい人間超越するんではないかという手術もできるし
その基準でブッダの教えと私は決定するんです
それはもう一応専門家のやり方でね
まあやってみれば何の間違いもなしと
誰にもこんなすごいことは言えませんしと
しかし 誰にもわかるし
心配そうに聞こえますけど
中国でも誰か言ったでしょ
すべての罪を犯すな そんなのは子供にでも言えますよと
それで禅師が訳の答えはそれはそうですよと
しかし 守るのは誰にもできませんよと
中学校のね ある禅師のところになんか偉い大王様か誰か来て
え？ブッダの教えって何なのか
偉そうな態度で こいつにもわからないんだから
そう言ったっても だから一番わかりやすいことを教えてあげた
なんだ そんなこと子供にも言えるんではないかと
すぐあの まあそうですけどね
守るのはね あんたにもできませんよと
仏教知ってる人はそういうことにすぐもう答え出します
まあそういうことで まあもうちょっとまあ明るく物事を見るとね
そんなに難しいことじゃないんですよ
まあやっぱり頭しっかりしてね
すごいもう反論 反論じゃなくてね
まあ説明して納得するようにできることはまあできるようになります
はい それで終了しますかね
一つの偈 もう一つに行くのはまたちょっと
次の偈は一応つなげてはありますがね
意味としては 今日はこの辺でやめたいと思ってます
これにはつなげてますけど
今日はまた次回説明しますけどね
ポイントは死に達した人は本当に少ないんだよと
例えば八十四番目で なんだ簡単ではないかということになるでしょうね
しかし簡単じゃない 本当に少ないんだよと
これやる人々はっていう
八十四と八十五 六はものすごく意味的にぴったし繋げているんです
では終了しましょう  では回向の文で終了したいと思います
座 please してください
回向の文  ルッゴーソーローの三宝に礼拝敬し
彼を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして平安が与えられますように
サッベーテェ ワッジャントゥ サッバローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワトゥ アンタラーヨー スキーディーガー
ユコー バワ バワトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバブッダヌバヴェーナ サッバダン
マヌバヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テアビワダナシーリッサ ニッチャンワッダー
パチャヤーノ チャッターローダンマワッダンティ アユアンノー スカンバラン
スワハティ スワハティ スワハティ
はい どうもありがとうございます